a discussion on decision trees is best
understood with an analogy of our daily
lives think about how we are often put
in situations where we make choices
based on certain condition where one
choice leads to a specific result or
consequence hello everyone my name is
mang and welcome to this fantastic video
on the decision tree algorithm in this
video we will delve into decision tre's
topics like what is decision tree the
advantages of decision tree moving
forward we will see applications of
decision tree and some important terms
used in decision tree at the end of this
video we will Implement Hands-On using
the decision tree algorithm just a quick
info for you decision tree is after all
an algorithm that is based on AI and
machine learning a professional who
wants to switch careers with AI and ml
by learning from their expert then try
giving simply learn postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning from P
University and collaboration with IBM in
this AIML course learn in demand skills
such as machine learning deep learning
and NLP computer vision reinforcement
learning generative AI prompt
engineering chat gbt and many more the
link in the description box should
navigate to the homepage where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered so take action upskill and
get ahead so without any further Ado
let's get started so what is a decision
tree a decision tree employed in
supervised learning is a tree like
structure designed to forast the outcome
of Target variable in supervised
learning which relies on label data
containing known output variables
predictions are made through regression
and classification algorithms these
algorithms serve as guide in training a
model with a predetermined output
variable by grasping uncomplicated
decision rules based on diverse data
features the model learns Python's
decision tree prove versatile handling
both classification and regression
challenges often finding application in
assessing probabilities so moving
forward let's see advantages of decision
tree decision tree are simple to
understand interpret and visualize the
second one is they can effectively
handle both numerical and categorical
data the third one is they can determine
the worst best and expected values for
several scenarios the last one is they
perform well even if the actual model
violates any assumptions so moving
forward we will discuss some decision
Tree application so the first one is a
decision tree is used to determine
whether an applicant is likely to
default on a loan the second one is it
can be used to determine the odds of a
individual developing a specific disease
the third one is it can help e-commerce
companies in predicting whether a
consumer is likely to purchase a
specific product or not the fourth one
is decent tree can also be used to find
customer churn rates so moving forward
we will see some important terms used in
decision trees so the first one is
entropy entropy is the major of
uncertainty or Randomness in a data set
entropy handles how a decision tree
splits the data the second one is
Information Gain The Information Gain
measure the decrease in entropy after
the data set is split the third one is
Guinea index the guinea index is used to
determine the correct variable for
splitting nodes it meas how often a
randomly choosen variable would be
incorrectly identified the fourth one is
root node the root node is always the
top node of a decent tree it represent
the entire population or data sample and
it can be further divided into different
data sets the fifth one is decision node
decision nodes are the subnodes that can
be split into different subnodes they
contain at least two branches the sixth
one is leaf node a leaf node in a
decision tree carries the final result
so these nodes which are also known as
terminal nodes cannot be split any
further so let's move forward to the
demo part so first we will rename this
Jupiter notebook uh like thisis
and this ision
three right
okay okay so first we will import some
major libraries like numai pandas M plot
lip SK learn seon so first we will
import import
pandas as
PD
right
okay SP SPD
then I will import
numi
numi as NP then I will
import M plot
Lim do
pyplot as
PLT then we will import eSalon and then
we will import Matrix on them so from
skan import
metrix right then we will import
cbor cbon as
SNS
from
skon
dot data
sets okay I will
import
load Iris so I will import the is data
set that's fler
one then moving forward we will import
some model selection skillon do
model
selection import
train
test
split
Ty then from SK Lear
import tree decision tree we will make
decision tree like tree shape structure
okay so let me run
is yes everything is
fine okay it's still loading yeah so
everything is fine so moving forward we
will import data set or you can say the
load data set we will load data Iris
equals to
load
Iris
right yes it's working fine then data
equals to PT
dot data
frame and data equals to iris.
data okay then comma
columns equals to Iris dot
feature
names okay then I will run
it if I will check data.
head what it will show see you can see
the data set sample length sample WID
petal length petal width
okay yes first give me
yes so let's make species as a Target
variable okay so first I will write here
data
species equals to Addis dot
Target then I will write here Target
equals
to NP
dot
unique and Idis Target isis. Target
okay then I will write Target n
variable equals to np.
Unique then
Iris dot Target
names
okay then
Target dictionary equals
to
dictionary in zip file then comma
Target comma Target
n underscore n right then moving forward
I will write data
species equals to
data
species
dot
replace Target
dictionary right let me run it okay it's
working fine so we set Target as a
species okay then now what we will do we
will make X and Y column okay for the
train and test split so I will write
here x equals to data dot
drop
columns right equals to
species then y equals to
data again
species write the
names underscore
features equals to X do
columns we are assigning names features
to X column and here I will write Target
labels
Target labels equals to Y do
unique
okay
okay so here we will split the data set
into train and the test okay so xcore
train comma xcore test comma y _
train comma Yore
test equals to
train
test
split X comma y
comma test size = to
0.3 comma
random random
State equals to
93 so what does this test size 0.3 means
so test size 0.3 means we are splitting
test and test data and the train data
into into 70% and the 30% right 70%
means training data the 30% is remaining
is the testing data okay so I will run
it
right so here I will write from
skar
dot tree
import
decision decision
tree
classifier
okay then here I will write DTC because
I can't write decision classifier again
again and
again decision
tree
classifier
max depth = to
comma random state to
93 okay DTC do
fit okay
no it's comma random state is
93 to
right then DTC do
fit X
train comma y
train okay then PLT do
figure
then figure
size equals to 30 comma
10 comma face color will
be face color equals to
B then I will write tree equals to tree.
plot underscore tree then and DTC
decision classifier comma features
name feature
names yeah features name comma class
names equals to
Target
labels
comma
rounded plus
true
then I will
write comma filled with True
Values comma font
size will be
okay yes so
now I will write
here B
do
show okay then y
prediction equals to DTC
dot
predict X
test okay decision tree classifier is
not
defined maybe some spelling mistake is
there
okay let me check
now okay feature names is not
defined okay where is feature names okay
features
name I feat
name okay okay this is names underscore
features right so what I will do I will
write First full
code then I will show you the
both graphs so I will write here
confusion
underscore
Matrix equals to
Matrix
dot
confusion
Matrix right then
y test comma y
prediction okay then
Matrix equals to PD dot data phrase
G
then
confusion Matrix okay we will create one
confusion Matrix
graph heat map so I will
write SNS
do heat
map
Matrix comma a
not to
true comma fmt = to
G
comma AIS equals to
AIS comma cmap sitemap equals to
magma then
AIS do
set
title is confusion
Matrix okay then we will set the x label
XT label y label y TX label okay then I
will write here
XIs do
set X
label
predicted
value comma font size
is = to
10 then
XIs
dot
set xti
label
labels
okay
plus
Target
labels then X this do
set
y tick labels then list will become then
Target labels will
show then I need one rotation of
zero equals to
Z then I will write
PLT dot
show okay so let me run it
so as you can see the decision
tree is here but there is confusion with
confusion Matrix
okay first I
will restart and clear all outputs I
will
do and let me run it
again okay so there is some
confusion okay so issue
is confusion matric is not
defined
okay it's Matrix now it will come yes so
as you can see confusion Matrix is here
and the decision tree this is how you
can make the decision tree we already
discussed this uh word Guinea right the
samples values so these patter length
patle width are from the data set got it
and this is confusion Matrix of
particular data set you can see we have
three categories Sosa versal and
virginica okay so we have come to end of
this video if you have any doubt please
ask in the comment section below our
team of expert will help you as soon as
possible thank you and keep learning but
simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here